[Musica]
fotografia
ho fatto delle foto
ho fotografato invece di parlare ho
fotografato per non dimenticare per
smettere di guardare così ha scritto
daniel pennac e forse è anche quello che
dovrei fare io stasera non parlarvi
semplicemente mostrarvi delle fotografie
perché è in questo che risiede quel
genio il nome ma specifico di cui si
parlava già roland barthes quella
capacità unica che la fotografia di
essere specchio e testimonianza della
realtà
al tempo stesso superandola è già
inscritto nella sua etimologia questa
potenza di rottura scrivere con la luce
luce e tempo la fotografia ha due
genitori molto illustri dall'ato
l'ottica dall'altro la chimica e figlia
dell'argento di quella materia viva che
l'alchimia medievale considerava capace
di intrappolare oggetti e persone
addirittura per sempre ma è anche figlia
dell'uomo come ha già avuto modo di
constatare nel 1544 leonardo da vinci
guardando un'eclissi solare attraverso
il foro stenopeico della sua camera
obscura perché anche la prima fotografia
che noi conosciamo della storia è
proprio un punto di vista e il po di
anni sforna epps dal suo studio ai tetti
di parigi da dentro a fuori e come ci
dice anche henri cartier bresson
è in questa sintesi che risiede la
fotografia nella dimensione dentro
fotografo che incontra quella esterna
è un punto d'incontro un equilibrio che
si concretizza in un attimo questo
legame con il suo referente questo che
fa della fotografia semioticamente
parlando un indice legame indiziale è
quello che inserisce la fotografia nei
segni come può essere loro ma quando
facciamo norma sulla sabbia alleghiamo
al nostro piede così la fotografia è
legata in qualche modo costretta
all'oggetto che rappresenta alcuni
scrittori pittori hanno sempre ravvisato
in questo sua natura un limite il limite
è dato dal fatto che lo scrittore un
pittore può raccontare quando vuole ciò
che vuole
mentre il fotografo è costretto in
qualche modo a quello che è adesso
questo è vero ma soltanto per chi non sa
vedere un infinita di possibilità nel
mondo che ci circonda perché non è la
tecnica a definire il fotografo ciò che
definisce un fotografo e il suo
atteggiamento rispetto alla tecnica
stessa c'è un aneddoto di simon evans
che ci racconta di un suo amico da un
certo punto va una sera a casa di una
signora e porta delle foto le mostra la
signora commenta bellissime deve avere
una macchina fotografica eccellente al
momento del congedo per il amico di
simon evans si rivolge alla signora
complimentandosi ottima cena deve avere
delle pentole di ottima qualità ma c'è
di più di questa realtà la fotografia ha
fatto il suo cavallo di battaglia perché
mentre una parola deve sempre dimostrare
alla fotografia semplicemente crediamo e
basta
ecco allora che la fotografia diventa
fotogiornalismo diventa lo strumento
principale di rottura denuncia
contestazione rivoluzione libertà e da
indice sposta il suo statuto a quello di
icona perché non è più semplicemente il
legame fisico con l'oggetto che
rappresenta né racconta anche il
significato e la forma ne diventa il
simbolo e questo lo fa raccontando i
grandi momenti della storia quelli
veramente di rottura ma lo fa anche
raccontando la quotidianità la
fotografia mostra al mondo intero che la
mediocrità di fatto è solo apparente
questa è una fotografia di martin parr
per esempio che ve lo racconta benissimo
le fotografie che state vedendo adesso
scorrere dietro di me sono tratte da una
mia selezione della special prince che
la magnum una delle agenzie fotografiche
più famose ogni anno fa vendendo a
prezzi ragionevoli delle foto del loro
archivio
l'anno scorso era proprio dedicato al
tema della libertà e anche per me è
stato lo stesso
io ho trovato la libertà in questo modo
ho cominciato a fotografare durante i
lunghi viaggi insieme a mio padre lui
scriveva e io a 13 anni ho provato ad
impugnare questa macchina fotografica
analogica a tentare più o meno di tenere
gli orizzonti diritti e in modo speciale
questa sera con voi
condivido quello che per me è stato e il
viaggio è decisivo fotograficamente e
anche personalmente un viaggio a cavallo
attraversando la mongolia verso il
confine con tu va verso questa
popolazione lizza ton che sono
allevatori di renne una popolazione
nomadica abbiamo così prese cavalli
attraversato l'infinita delle steppe
mongole ci siamo fermati come diritto ad
ogni girl remota perché lì la notizia
viene portato umanamente personalmente
sorseggiando tè salato bevendo ai raid
incontrando gli sciamani e poi poco a
poco
siamo saliti dalla di bianchi e siamo
arrivati al campo base
il più remoto perché nella stagione
estiva si allontanano di più lizza ton
erano decimati dalla febbre maltese che
era veicolata attraverso le renne e
attraverso
le pecore mongole e noi abbiamo passato
questo tempo con loro semplicemente
stando lì vivendole con la mia macchina
fotografica ha documentato l'aiuto
mattinali tario che ne avevamo portato
quindi soldi farina zucchero giornali
quaderni per i bambini questo è il
regalo che ci hanno fatto in cambio un
cucciolo di renna bianca questo
orizzonte mi è rimasto dai tori di sunny
per sempre dentro e non ho mai smesso di
viaggiare da allora ho continuato a
viaggiare ho continuato a fotografare
come già vi anticipavo anche carlo la
mia dimensione preferita di viaggio e
quella solitaria via terra questo perché
mi permette di rompere il tempo di ogni
giorno mi permette di arrivare
camminando dopo km chilometri ad un
momento in cui scatta qualcosa c'è con
un click in cui si diventa più
percettivi nei confronti del mondo
esterno
ma non solo anche nei confronti di se
stessi è però per capire profondamente
questa esperienza io ho bisogno della
fotografia perché la fotografia è un
tempo che mi permette di fermarmi in
qualche modo di fermare dei dettagli di
leggere
dei dettagli che altrimenti non avrei
mai notato sarà capitato anche a voi di
scattare una fotografia e poi notare
delle cose che al momento non avevate
nemmeno visto la fotografia è un tempo
che ha bisogno di tempo ma è anche
perché il nostro pensiero passa dalla
parola se ci pensate
la fotografia a un altro canale che è
diversa è quello non verbale e allora
questo canale non verbale diventa una
possibilità fortissima per l'incontro
per l'incontro anche con popoli che
paradossalmente non parla noto lingua io
ho girato abbastanza lungo
l'oriente perché è diventato il mio
grande amore mio mi ha veramente
affascinato dalla russia alla cina gli
stan all'indocina
potete tranquillamente girarla senza
necessariamente parlare la loro lingua è
utile qualche base di russo ai confini
soprattutto degli stand però potete
anche capire molto poco per esempio di
mandarino la fotografia comunque ve lo
permette
nel frattempo però che cosa è successo è
successa una cosa importante dalla
pellicola si è passata al digitale
le prime foto deliziata n'erano ancora
in pellicola poi tutte le altre che
avete vista sono in digitale e
l'immagine si è svuotata nel senso che
il simulacro diventato sempre più
sintetico è diventato sempre meno calco
è sempre più simulato della realtà
questo significa centinaia di migliaia
di foto condiviso ogni secondo significa
una possibilità effettivamente
incredibile e c'è la possibilità di
viaggiare senza nemmeno spostarsi c'è la
possibilità di informarsi senza leggere
non chi ignora l'alfabeto
ma chi ignora la fotografia sarà un
alfabeto del futuro questa una bella
problematica a cui forse avremmo dovuto
pensare un pochino prima ma qui
sicuramente dobbiamo pensare adesso se
solo guardate instagram capite quanto è
un mezzo potente dal punto di vista
della linguistica è incredibile perché è
un mezzo che riesce a parlare di
immagine attraverso l'immagine senza
avere bisogno dell'apporto della parola
quindi parla di per sé non ha non ha un
filtro questo dovrebbe fare di instagram
oltre due ragioni principali ovvero aver
messo dei filtri buoni per delle
telecamere inizialmente cattive e avere
una buona condivisione per gli altri
social
lo strumento di liberazione per tutti
quanti ombretti bradley per tutti
eppure qualcosa è andato storto
meno che mai una semplice resa del reale
dice qualcosa sulla realtà e che cosa è
successo è successo che siamo
sovraccarichi di immagini non capiamo
nemmeno bene più forse come leggerle
sono troppe addirittura noi stessi ne
facciamo troppe forse visto che ce le
dimentichiamo nella casa del cellulare e
cosa è venuto a mancare il fatto è che
l'omologazione il confine fra
l'omologazione e la libertà si è fatto
sempre più sottile e ci ha messo un po
in una gabbia e soprattutto si può fare
un immagine ma una fotografia un po
diverso è venuto a mancare quel punto di
vista di cui abbiamo parlato fino a qui
la fotografia è stata scaricata di tutte
quelle sue caratteristiche impotenza e
allora ha senso ancora oggi essere
fotografi professionisti ha senso fare
una fotografia
quando l'immagine oramai dialoga con noi
con un rapporto del tutto diverso con
l'evento il fatto la conoscenza
secondo me sì sì perché sarebbe sciocco
avere una tecnologia come giustamente di
sé ma anche gabriele prima a nostra
disposizione per non usarla per non
sfruttarla per non usare al meglio però
deve un po cambiare il rapporto che il
fotografo invece a con la fotografia col
proprio pubblico col proprio lettore
l'ho fatto anch'io ho fatto una scelta
diversa
ho fatto questa scelta che vedete
scorrere che è oggi una associazione ma
di cui io sono diventata prima
caporedattore win journal nasce nell
2017 come scusate nel 2007 come primo
prima rivista di fotogiornalismo online
da un progetto editoriale del fotografo
e giornalista amedeo novelli e poi si
trasforma in un'associazione portata
avanti da fotografi fotografi che hanno
una missione diversa hanno una missione
di fare cultura fotografica di
integrazione socializzazione è una
contaminazione è qualcosa che è stata
aperta non solo ai fotografi
professionisti ma a professionalità
diverse perché in realtà quello che
conta è raccontare le storie quelle
importanti ma anche quelle del
quotidiano perché noi siamo convinti che
comunque la voce del quotidiano che
altrimenti viene fuori è attraverso i
social sia un momento veramente
importante e sia anche la costruzione
sia un momento eccezionale da seguire e
allora essere fotoreporter oggi in un
paradigma che è complesso e liquido è
stratificato e tecnologicamente avanzato
significa ancora di più essere capaci di
far vedere e intravedere il futuro non
si fotografa con la meccanica si
fotografa con l'occhio del cuore e con
una buona fotografia noi lettori
possiamo sapere chi siamo
[Musica]
e forse anche chi saremo
[Applauso]